hey guys it is the second day of III
press conferences and we kick today off
big with Microsoft from their new
console to all the games we're here to
catch you up so stick with us for the
next few minutes we won't waste time and
Microsoft did an either on getting to
the meat of their presentation project
Scorpio or as we now know it Xbox one
x-man I was hoping for natal first up we
got a look at the box and it looks like
well a black xbox one but it's actually
going to be the smallest Xbox ever the
$500 machine is equipped with an 8 core
CPU 6 teraflop GPU and 12 gigabytes of
gddr5 Ram as we expected Xbox 1x is
going all-in on 4k with HDR Microsoft
promises 8 million active pixels and
that even those playing in traditional
1080p will be able to notice the
difference through super sampling
Microsoft announced that all your Xbox
one games and accessories will work with
Xbox one X and it'll be up on November 7
but what's a cool box without being able
to see what it can do the first of the
games Microsoft revealed running on Xbox
one X was flotsam motorsport 7 not only
was it the worldwide reveal of the game
but also the worldwide reveal of the
Porsche 2018 911 gt2 RS both in game and
IRL there will be more than 700 cars
available in the game and it will be
quote the most technically advanced and
comprehensive racing game when it
launches on October 3
Fortson motorsport 7 will run in 4k at
60 frames per second on xbox one x-man
that is already really hard to say
Microsoft also debuted the world
premiere of Metro Exodus the new title
from for a games the gameplay trailer
showed off ominous apocalyptic ruins
skeletons and big nasty beasties of
course we saw two different weapons a
rifle and a crossbow before the
protagonist met up with a companion
aboard a massive train the game is
launching in 2018 after all those leaks
we finally got our first official look
at the next Assassin's Creed Assassin's
Creed origins and yep we're headed to
Egypt the main character is by yak the
last of the Magi
we saw swimming rafting a giant Cobra
and of course parkour the game features
literal Falcon vision to tag enemies and
set waypoints counter heavy combat and
camel riding interests
eub of said they have added deeper RPG
elements Assassin's Creed origins will
release October 27
yeah gave us a taste of Bioware's new IP
anthem yesterday but today at Microsoft
we got much more anthem will feature a
huge lush open world for you and your
friends to explore game director John
Warner showed off a gameplay trailer
with a crowded market a giant mechanical
beast and an NPC in need of help the
game lets you equip unique javelin
exosuits
which can be equipped with jetpacks
mortars homing rockets and Shane guns
everything you need to explore and
survive the hostile lands anthem also
features dynamic weather and we have an
expected release window in 2018 let me
take a deep breath because there's still
more Microsoft's revealed the player
unknowns battlegrounds is coming to Xbox
with Xbox 1x enhancements to follow
Microsoft also debuted fighting game at
Dragon bull fighters II or fighters they
only put it up on screen which as you
can imagine features Dragon Ball
characters in beautiful cel-shaded 3v3
matches its drought in early 2018 xbox
will also get the console exclusive
launch of MMORPG black desert online
state of decay to made an appearance via
a gameplay trailer which showed a group
of survivors banding together before the
trailer closed on a player choice we got
to look at base customization looting
and the tough choices players will need
to make to survive the apocalypse don't
fret
you won't have to make those tough
choices for a little while as state of
decay 2 launches spring 2018 of course
it wouldn't be a Microsoft presser
without Minecraft and the big news for
this one is that the game now creatures
cross play across all platforms that's
right every device on the planet that
has Minecraft will now be able to play
with every other device that has
minecraft there's also a super-duper
graphics pack coming this fall that adds
reflections godrays and 4k support and
that's all free High Point is so much
more I know how long is it like 20
minutes on the stylish front we saw a
brief trailer for the last night a
cyberpunk game that mixes lush high
fidelity visuals and lighting with pixel
art characters it totally looks like
Gemini Roo and I am on board for on its
heels was a platformer with a paper
character who wields a magical guitar
called The Artful escape vampire
action game code vane got another look
in that showed off more gorgeous visuals
and a release date of 2018 the game that
shouldn't be nearly as fun as it is rez
multiplayer pirate adventure sea of
thieves got a brand new gameplay trailer
that included all sorts of shenanigans
like exploring a sunken ship and an
overgrown island finding treasure and
fending off sharks and skeletons the
gameplay demo also introduced trading
and shooting yourself out of a cannon
because why not unless cool news sea of
thieves has been delayed until early
2018 but Tacoma a stylish sci-fi game
from gone home developer fulbright got a
release date of August 2nd swings and
roundabouts Microsoft showed off a
gameplay trailer for the bright and
colorful platformer super Lucky's tale
which will arrive exclusively on Xbox
one on November 7 and the perpetually
unreleased cuphead finally got a release
date of September 29
finally in things that make press
conferences better a trailer featuring
Terry Crews introduced crackdown 3 and
the bright neon gunshots were plentiful
we also got the news that the shooter
will arrive on November 7 how is there
still more shadow of war the sequel to
middle-earth shadow of Mordor then took
the spotlight the highlight definitely
being Bruce the Ozzy or Brian Lord our
Lord same thing really
there will be seven Orca tribes in the
sequel as well as the greatly expanded
open-world you'll be able to forge an
army of followers and assault nemesis
fortresses unfortunately the gameplay
demo ended just before Italians assault
but you'll be able to play shadow of war
for yourself on October 8 in things that
excite me we got our first proper look
at an older and presumably wiser max in
life is strange before the storm and the
weight isn't too bad either as the first
episode of three will arrive on August
31st and the sequels didn't stop there
get your fields in check because Ori and
the will of the wisps is on the way with
gorgeous music lovely visuals and
touching critters no release date for
that one yet though Microsoft was only
not done with the surprises though as
the gigantic chair of the show so far
was won by the news that original Xbox
game
including crimson skies will now be
included in xbox one
backwards-compatibility
so that's everything for Microsoft stick
with us because we will be covering
every press conference or e3 and do you
remember to pick up the game spot now
app which is free on iOS and Android so
you don't miss out on any of the news we
will see you again later for Podesta